[Music]
Jon Arryn is dead I know he was like a
father to you John was a man of peace
why kill him he started asking questions
I've heard it said that poison is a
woman's weapon yes women Cravens and
unit that's all the realm is now
backstabbing and scheming and
money-grubbing who but you can protect
the kill
they killed my husband this people will
do anything
all of the power is yours you need only
reach out and take it if we don't act
there will be a war you condemn yourself
with your own mouth seize this traitor
they said they were going to kill you
strike tonight while the castle sleeps
I know the truth Gennaro died fool
[Music]